did a husband cross the line when he
left his wife at the airport yeah throw
the whole wife away first of all he was
going to visit his daughter so when the
wife decided to go to another terminal
with 15 minutes for her then he did the
right thing and he got his butt on that
plane to go see his daughter these women
giving their opinions on talk shows I
don't usually agree with but today I I
actually wholeheartedly agree look it
what what is true feminine and I thought
about how interesting it was we have all
these like femininity coaches coming out
about fashion makeup hair and just
focusing on yourself the true femininity
is listening to the men in your life and
focusing on the men around you like did
our great grandmothers did they really
care about the fashion the makeup the
botox like all that night the greatest
Memories We have with women are women
that were absolutely selfless and
unfortunately the women of today we
don't really have gold standard women
anymore